as mentioned at the top of the show
there are intense arguments tonight
about money to pay for hurricane relief
past present and future chief White
House correspondent John Roberts has
that part of the story tonight as
hurricane Dorian churns off the Puerto
Rico Coast a political tempest erupting
between San Juans Mayor Carmen Ely and
Cruz and President Trump after the
president tweeted Congress approved
ninety two billion dollars for Puerto
Rico last year Cruz fired back Congress
has approved 40 billion and 14 billion
have been dispersed to which President
Trump replied Puerto Rico is one of the
most corrupt places on earth adding and
by the way I'm the best thing that's
ever happened to Puerto Rico in truth
Congress approved forty two point seven
billion dollars for Puerto Rico of that
about twenty-one million has been
obligated and less than fourteen billion
spent to get to ninety two billion the
president is including an OMB estimate
that an additional fifty billion will be
needed over the life of the recovery but
it's not money approved by Congress
President Trump also found himself under
attack over plans to reprogram money
from FEMA's disaster relief fund to
address the border crisis as part of a
271 million dollar shuffle DHS will use
a hundred and fifty five million of FEMA
money to pay for temporary immigration
hearing facilities on the southern
border another 116 million dollars will
be taken from other agencies to pay for
more single adult detention beds
Democrats were quick to condemn the move
in a statement House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi saying to pick the pockets of
disaster relief funding in order to fund
an appalling inhumane family
incarceration plan is staggering and to
do so on the eve of hurricane season
he's stunningly reckless White House
officials pushed back just as hard
that's hysteria and the reality is that
this is something that Republican
Democrat administrations do constantly
is to reprogram to ours in fact
President Obama did the same thing in
August of 2014
shifting even more money to the border
crisis of a total of four hundred and
five billion dollars reprogrammed two
hundred and sixty seven point six
million came from FEMA's Disaster Relief
Fund Democrats didn't argue with that
but they sure are complaining now
Senator Chuck Schumer saying taking
these critical funds from disaster
preparedness and recovery efforts
threatens lives and weakens the
government's ability to help Americans
in the wake of natural disasters FEMA
officials say no in fact that is not the
case that the money comes from an
account that's dedicated to pre
positioning supplies ahead of a
hurricane and that there's plenty of
money in that account to last until the
end of the fiscal year another account
that actually deals with recovery is
flush with cash
it has a balance of 27 billion dollars
and I should make a correction Brad it
was 405 million dollars not billion
dollars that were reprogrammed in the
Obama administration